what happens when someone comes to you
and says here's a period film what goes
through your head
um with this film uh i must say i think
i sought it because i knew the story i
had read a book about epi grey and the
period of art is something that i'm very
very passionate about it's a period i
know very well i come from manchester
and um the manchester art gallery
has an enormous amount of
pre-raphaelite and and
late victorian paintings so it was
something that i really wanted to do and
i really wanted to do it in a specific
way do you go to the character first or
to the period when you have such an
assignment well um i knew the period uh
but you really go to the character first
i mean i'm a great believer that this
job my job my wonderful job is about
storytelling more than anything else and
if you lose that
you don't get the same sort of texture
we were speaking just a bit before we
came up about the difference between
doing costumes for stage and costumes
for film can you speak about that a
little bit yes uh i started in the
theater and i oh i mean since being a
very young child all i wanted to do was
work in the theater but the moment that
i walked onto a film set i knew that
i had no
uh the thing about films is you can tell
secrets and you can tell secrets in all
sorts of ways you can help with the
character you can expand you can go into
you can minimize things that so it's a
much
much more exquisite medium for someone
like me you can still do your big
strokes i mean there are lots of big
strokes in this but you also get to do
all the private little moments so
there's a close-up of a cuff for example
that would have an intimacy that a stage
even the same piece of clothing on stage
would not carry over that's right
and and for this film in particular
where did you begin to look because the
past to us is a black and white
existence
where do where do you look for the
authenticity of color and texture well
in this film i looked at the paintings
um and they're rich and they're vital
someone asked me the other day how
accurate the costumes were and i said
not
incredibly accurate and they were
confused but where they weren't accurate
which was that i did try and
use the paintings as reference rather
than real costumes victorian costumes
are heavy
and they are um they're wonderful but
they are pretty determined in themselves
and they move in a pretty they could
stand up right by them yeah they move
like motor cars slow motor cars
so um you know what i tried to do is was
give it some sense of the lyricism so
i'd used very different underpinnings i
was very careful in fabrics we sprayed
into fabric so we got a lot of the sense
of depth
it was a very very fun job do you get to
insist that the actors wear the same
undergarments that they would in these
period costumes as well yes and if
you're a hero like dakota fanning you
allow yourself to be put into a course
and have your waist pulled into 21
inches
without complaining really that's a
trooper that is a trooper she is a very
very wonderful girl for costuming her
character in particular
the transition from young girl to bride
and then bride to wife who wasn't a wife
you still had a sense of of her virginal
state throughout how did you develop
that and evolve it um it's a lovely
story her story it's a lovely journey
and and um
visually it's a lovely journey because
she starts off as this very
young
inexperienced innocent girl in scotland
when she first comes to london i think
there's a real feeling that she is
unsuitable in london and in fact there's
a cat which so
you don't get when she comes downstairs
in the pink dress and they send her back
to
and put on a rather gloomy green dress
that she then goes to the dinner in so
she comes not knowing her way around she
then becomes more and more repressed by
what's going on
um and more and more unhappy which i
think you know i hope you see in the
costumes you see her
going more and more into herself the
necks get higher the
um
they get heavier uh and then she hits
venice and she hits venice like we all
hit venice and she hits the shop she
hits
the live she goes ooh
this is it and you see her completely
flower in venice as a person
emotionally she's still having a
terrible time but you see her taking
control of herself as a person
then she comes back and it's even worse
she then goes to scotland which is where
her heart is so in scotland the clothes
very much were
of organically involved with the
countryside which she knew much simpler
too
interestingly or interestingly for me
uh
milay did a lot a lot of drawings of her
in scotland so there was a lot of lovely
line drawings that it was possible to
use as reference which was a big treat
and not a usual thing
then she comes back from scotland and
things
have gone from back to worse except she
has what she knows
she's in a chrysalis state so in all the
clothes that she wears after scotland
you see
a little touch of what's going to come
out when she's at the lawyer she has
this very stern
seriously heavy victorian outfit but she
has a fluffy little shadow at her and
what i was trying to do was give that
sense of i mean it was storytelling um
and of course the sort of cape at the
end which is alive uh you know the idea
was that the color and the movement of
it you would feel that life was really
breaking through and it was like the sun
coming out like the scene of her
spinning in the piazza that was nice in
venice which was lovely yes and uh also
traditionally once you got married in
victorian england you wore your hair up
but her hair was down like a young
woman's for a long time
i think she was young and i i think he
would have hated her to have had her
hair up oh so this was yet more of his
dictates you got the sense that he was
of course very controlling about
everything yes and uh and for him with
his blue um ascot his uh his his neck
neck scarf the whole time
here's a man who had an immense
influence on the aesthetic of the 19th
century and yet i don't think i would
have liked him very much at all
i don't know that many people
did you have to convey important yes uh
to the art world hugely yeah can let's
put this a little closer oh yes
so how did you convey apart from the
consistency of that blue scarf how did
you convey well it is conservative too
you do get a sense that he is a man who
is trapped also trapped in his own body
and that hope the costume somehow helped
that and the fact that he really didn't
change
and he did have a lot of the same
costume we did in fact make him a lot of
the same costume because it seemed like
a good idea that we should feel that
that he was always changing from one
costume to the same costume to the same
costume and he had that sense of
rigidity about him
uh the the character played by julie
walters his mother uh there's a phrase
in england which we should actually
learn here in beverly hills called
mutton dressed as lamb which is older
women dressing far too young and i got
the sense that she was seducing her son
still and the clothes were just a little
bit too young maybe a little bit too
daring yes exactly it made me laugh i
suddenly remembered when you were
talking about corsets that the only
person who did complain about her course
it was julie and i think that was part
of the character that this character is
sort of trying to pull herself into this
but you know she's she's got a lovely
round womanly figure and um that she
somehow
um
was trying to
um avoid
i thought of mary todd lincoln when i
saw her carrying along like a great ship
under sail like a sofa i mean she does
look as though she's upholstered and you
know padded out and something you could
possibly sit on but her character was so
flirtatious with her son
that i looked i saw that in the
costuming as well
and that was a reality too she did go to
oxford with him
when people you know when all our
children as 18 go up on their own she
did go
my goodness
and no wonder the scene with the shirts
like don't touch his shirts oh wow
and and what about the emma thompson
character there was something almost
18th century about the way she was
dressing what did you want to convey oh
well
20th century but maybe no but i saw the
duchess of devonshire in her hair yes i
just wanted her to be her own person and
i really wanted with her because of who
she is is to the peace and because of
the sort of life
that emma has i wanted you to feel that
she wasn't a conventional victorian
person that she wasn't one of that she
was a wife with real spirit i mean she
really is the conduit that
gets effie into who she is she might
never have done it without her so i did
not want you to feel that this was a
conventional woman i wanted you to feel
that this was a woman with great flair
and her own sense of artistry and her
own sense of who she was in the world